[Musique]
alors vous le reconnaissez ouai mais jp
c'est lui qui fait la marche renaud
regarde tomber
merci merci du sommet du g20 pourquoi tu
ne vas pas appelé pour ça marche vous
c'est à dire nous les rebeus lé juif
marché contre le racisme marché contre
les discriminations marchés arabes et
noirs est juif et j'ai que demain j'ai
que demain
les noirs et les arabes on est des
frères ok mais on est des frères que
quand ça vous arrange jetterait vous
évidemment fu chi dans ce salon
laisserait sa soeur se mettre avec un
noir qui tue pas de sens pourquoi je
veux pas que vous veniez en marche pour
évaluer votre image vous savez ce qu'il
vous faut
très bonne marche c'est un triathlon qui
voit là bas c'est une vanne